nicolas hulot je vous le disais se
rappelle au bon souvenir des candidats
qui ont signé son pacte écologique
premier temps fort de la journée au
zénith il a appelé les politiques à a
lancé une mutation écologique pour
tenter de sauver la planète
deuxième temps fort face à la tour
eiffel une une véritable démonstration
de force
à trois semaines du premier tour de la
présidentielle nicolas hulot exige que
les promesses soient tenues
cécile annonce alexandre dupont nicolas
hulot acclamé comme un candidat qui
brigue l'elysée sur l'esplanade du
trocadéro
dix mille personnes sont venues écouter
son scénario catastrophe pour la planète
auprès de l'animateur télé
beaucoup d'artistes lebesson zazie marc
lavoine pascal obispo
tous soutiennent le grand retour de
nicolas hulot sur le devant de la scène
son but forcer le faste écologique au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle
aucun acquis sociaux social pardon ne
pourra résister à la combinaison de la
pauvreté de l'effondrement nos
ressources naturelles et des
conséquences en cascade et imprévisible
et changement climatique le
réchauffement de la planète le
développement durable relégué aux
oubliettes
qu'à cela ne tienne depuis quelques
jours nicolas hulot rencontre les
candidats et leur rappelle leurs
engagements pris hier nicolas sarkozy
lui a même promis s'il est élu sans
d'organiser dès septembre un grenelle de
l'environnement aux politiques de
profiter de cet espace que vous venez de
leur dégager
on leur dit allez-y borgo je préfère
avoir déçu quelques personnes en ne
présentant pas
avoir déçu beaucoup en présentant et on
n'était pas forcément à la hauteur de
leur histoire
une démarche qui fait du militant des
people moi j'ai une fille et j'aimerais
bien que dans cinquante ans je suis j'ai
vu une baleine elles me disent oui ça
bien sûr avec elle elle qu'elle
comprenne ce que je veux dire
nicolas hulot sait que c'est quelqu'un
qui dit la vérité voilà tout simplement
et la vérité c'est la nourriture de
l'esprit donc on est content on est
rassasié commentant ce à quoi ils ont
dans la foule
josé bové rester en retrait il fait
partie des cinq candidats s'ils ont
signé le pacte écologique
mais pour le 22 avril nicolas hulot ne
donne aucune consigne ou presse juste
voté pour la planète oui je sais qu'avec